hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to be
talking about Bernard Davis's u-tube
experiment which is the experiment that
proves that direct cell contact was
necessary for conjugation to occur
between two bacteria so first let's
start by talking about bacterial
conjugation what is it it is when
genetic material is transferred from a
donor cell to a recipient cell
specifically through direct cell to cell
contact this happens by way of a
structure called a pillow
so the pill s also known as a sex palace
or conjugation palace is constructed by
the donor cell to allow it to attach to
a recipient cell and then exchange
genetic information so for example this
donor cell has a plasmid the recipient
cell does not the plasmid can include
lots of genes including genes for pillo
synthesis but also genes for things like
toxin production or antibiotic
resistance genes or whatnot
and so with the process of conjugation a
copy of this plasmid is made and then
given to the recipient cell and that's
conjugation the fact that direct cell
contact was necessary for this process
was proven by Bernard Davis with this
YouTube experiment he used bacteria
known as auxotrophs
so auxotrophs are mutants that require
an added nutrient they will not grow on
just a minimal media they have to have
some nutrient added to that media
whereas the original strain the
unmutated strain could make that
nutritional component itself and
therefore could grow on minimal media
but the auxotrophs have picked up some
mutation and now they need some other
nutrient added in order to be able to
grow so let's look at the two
auxotrophic strains that Bernard Davis
used strain a is what we call t minus L
minus b1 minus B plus M plus and all
this means is that where it has a plus
it can make that nutrient it can make
biotin and it can make methane amine but
it's been mutated so that its genes that
allowed it to make threonine leucine and
thiamine have are no longer functional
so we write T minus L minus and b1 minus
the B
as for thiamine which is a B vitamin
that's where that nomenclature comes
from so that was strain a it could make
its own bytes in the thymine but needed
the other three to be supplemented in
its media strain b was just the opposite
it was t plus L plus b1 plus B minus M
minus so it was perfectly capable of
making its own threonine leucine and
thiamine but it could not make its own
biotin and Metheny those things had to
be added to its its media in order for
it to be able to grow so he said at this
YouTube experiment called YouTube
because the tube is in the shape of a U
and there was a filter in the middle and
the filter would allow solution from
either side to pass through but not the
cells so the solution could move through
these pores but the cells themselves
were sequestered on either side so
strain a was added to this side strain B
was added to this side there is a cotton
plug on one end there was also a rubber
plug on the other end with a hollow
glass tube it was used to apply either
pressure or suction so pressure would
push the solution this way suction would
pull the solution this way and so the
solution that each strain was in could
go back and forth but the cells
themselves had to stay on either side
and the key here is that if conjugation
was possible without direct cell contact
remember that this experiment was done
long before we knew about the pillows if
conjugation was possible without cell
without direct cell contact then you
would expect a proto truth to form a pro
truth is just a strain that has that has
obtained the the previous unmutated
strains functions what we mean by that
is here we have strain a remember it's
lacking the genes to make three things
we have strain B which
has those three things but is lacking
the genes to make the other two things
which strain can make and so if
recombination occurs between these cells
if they're able to exchange genetic
material then we would expect these two
things to happen where they exchange
some DNA and you get some cells that
have all five non-functional mutant
genes and other cells that are capable
of making all five of those nutrients
themselves
this right here is what's called the
protozoa so it is no longer auxotrophic
it has regained the ability to grow in
minimal media so if no direct contact
was required you would see the
appearance of prototypes so bernard
davis of this experiment he did the
pressure and the suction back and forth
to mix the solution of those cells and
then he took cells from this arm plated
them on minimal media south from this
arm plated them on minimal media and
here are his results neither side
yielded cells that could grow on that
minimal media so there were no pro the
tropes that formed
and the fact that there were no proto
probes proved that direct contact was
required was required that this filter
right here that separated the two cells
kept them from being able to do
bacterial conjugation kept them from
being able to exchange genetic material
if he did the same experiment without
the filter where the cells were able to
have direct contact then proto troops
would have formed and so that is how he
proves it direct cell contact was
necessary for conjugation and then at a
later point when during microscopy was
improved the the sex pilis was
discovered at that point so if you are
interested in learning more about
conjugation I do have a more in-depth
video that covers this subject of
bacterial conjugation so please check
that out if you're interested and thanks
for watching biology professor